[Music]
some of you guys might be familiar with
my father we've been playing some real
voicemails that he leaves me on this
show and uh since we've been doing that
a funny thing has happened uh he's now
kind of uh how to say this haming it up
he's haming it up I think he's now
trying listen to me this is my weird
reality my father now leaves me
voicemails where I get this the distinct
sense that he's trying to get on the
show still funny little different check
it out in this installment of voicemails
from my
dad this is your father speaking from
the East Coast over here how you doing
how you doing Peter uh you know ever
since that show that you know your
mother and I went to and uh we appeared
there and all this stuff and you
introduced me John Holmes and all this
stuff I keep getting these calls from
these people about thinking that I'm
some kind of far away porn star you have
to you have to clarify this Peter this
this can't go on and I went on and on
with these people and finally I had to
tell them look I don't care my name is
John Holmes but I'm no porn star and and
further all in our branch of the Holmes
family that porn star that you're
referring to was known as
shorty you get my message don't forget
to call your mother
ciao yeah my dad is not a porn star
clarify that for you
[Music]
pop